let's talk about wealth poverty and
healthcare we've known for a while that
the American healthcare act dubbed
Republic air Ryan care some people want
to call it come care unclear exactly how
involved Trump was with the writing of
it although recently Paul Ryan says
Trump was very involved we've known for
a while that the AHEA would primarily
help rich investors and hurt many of the
people who actually voted for Donald
Trump people in the working class we've
known that for a while intuitively we've
known it from looking at the bill
proposal but Donald Trump himself has
actually come out now and admitted that
the new Republican health care bill that
he favors would be really good for rich
people and really bad for many of trumps
working-class voters
you might remember as I told you
yesterday that Donald Trump was
interviewed on Fox News by Tucker
Carlson and yesterday we played some
clips related to the wiretapping claims
I have another segment of this interview
that I want to play for you today
during the interview Tucker Carlson
asked Trump what do you think about all
the criticism that the health care bill
is going to help the wealthy and hurt
lower middle income people and Trump
without missing a beat says yeah I know
that that's what the bill will do
arguing this isn't the final bill but
readily admitting that that is exactly
what the result of the bill is written
would be take a look this bill has as
one of its centerpieces a tax cut for
investors that would primarily benefit
people making over two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year already done
pretty well in the past ten years as you
know you know a Bloomberg analysis
showed that counties that voted for you
middle-class and working-class counties
would do far less well under this bill
that accountability more affluent anger
it seems like making and is it
consistent with the message of the last
election a lot of things aren't
consistent this is going to be the
notion yeah many of the things that
Trump is doing or not at all consistent
with the message of the election I've
been looking Pat for any instance of
Trump being honest we got it it's 29
seconds with Tucker Carlson admitting
that much of what he's doing
legislatively or attempting to do is not
at all consistent with the message of
the campaign readily admitting that with
the explanation that nothing is
finalized right everything seems
backwards here you have dawn
Trump being honest for once and II have
Tucker Carlson seeming to argue for
liberal ideals yeah that there's been a
massive redistribution of the wealth to
the top one percent over ten years which
there has been no doubt about it and
Trump Trump knows all of it apparently
folks now Trump's position that this is
all just temporary in preliminary it's
not really the attitude of many of the
Republicans that are pushing this bill
Paul Ryan and lots of other Republicans
seem very proud of the bill they want to
see it pass in a condition in a state as
close to the initial proposal as
possible we've seen that s feeding grin
that Paul Ryan had on his face at the
beginning of the first press conference
where he held up the bill and said
something like here it is this is what
I've been working towards my entire
career Trump just doesn't want to be
responsible for the awful health care
bill even though at this point so many
people including Trump and Ryan
themselves have acknowledged yet Trump
was involved in the formulation of this
bill so either they're lying and Trump
didn't really come up with any of the
tenants in the bill because he's not
really what you call a quote policy guy
or Trump did have input into the process
and maybe that's why the bill is so bad
and now Trump is trying to back out of
taking or receiving any credit for it
for the remainder of this entire
interview with Tucker Carlson Trump
didn't say anything else to address the
way in which the American Health Care
Act will screw over middle and lower
class people it was acknowledged by
Trump it was admitted by Trump it was
written off as preliminary and not
mentioned again I'll remind you an
analysis by health policy experts has
figured out that the American Health
Care Act in its current form would add
1542 dollars to the cost of the average
enrollee
per year and that number would increase
over time the Congressional Budget
Office estimates that twenty four
million people
Americans will lose coverage by 2026 and
there's been an analysis done by Think
Progress and we talked about life or
death
I think progress analysis estimates that
somewhere around 17,000 people who would
be okay or at least alive under Obama
care could die next year if the respond
in health care bill is passed and that
this number would only grow over time
Trump knows at this point right Pat that
this plan as proposed would be a
disaster for Americans I think so that's
why he didn't even try to defend that he
said a lot of things are inconsistent
which is perhaps the worst argument I've
ever heard for anything yeah we talked a
lot about what will make Trump
supporters jump ship if they lose their
Medicare coverage or Medicaid I guess it
would be good either yeah if your
pocketbook is affected that's that's one
of those things that impacts you so
personally that you would have to
I hope you're right because you what
you're saying is perfectly logical but I
still think that they're going to sit
around and find somebody else to blame
it's really sad that most of trumps
voters won't even be exposed to this
information - you know the small
percentage of the country that watches
Tucker Carlson but many of the trumpet's
that are exposed to the reality will
probably rationalize it or find somebody
else to blame because it's tough to
admit that you're wrong especially when
you've been holding this guy up for the
past year or two as the saint-like
figure yeah and now you have to change
your perception of who he actually is
buyer's remorse cognitive dissonance
it's all happening overlapping biases
and heuristics at play here and we'll be
covering it Gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer com
/t DPS the games are shipped directly to
you would return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the David Pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s